your brain is capable of anything I mean
my new book is exactly about that it's
exactly about your brain being able to
uh to do anything what you tell it to do
right but if you leave it uncontrolled
it's tendency it's instinct is to look
for what's wrong why because it's a it's
a survival machine yes it is there for
the simple reason of detecting if there
is a tiger so it can protect you okay
and yes if there are no tigers that can
go on and invent iPhones but but you
know if but it's still even as it's
inventing iPhones trying to detect
everything it's my boss Annoying It's My
you know boyfriend girlfriend
you know trying to leave me or you know
am I going to starve whatever right but
that's until you take charge if you take
charge you know that little voice in
your head I basically say it's like your
computer it's like your device you can
tell it what to do and it will do it and
once you start to take charge that
machine can be instructed to look for
what's right